so yeah i'm sure you saw everything that
happened
what happened okay oh yeah the video
came out so uh if you weren't at work i
know you're on tour they sent us a bunch
of copyright strikes 20 of them 20
strikes 20 strikes bro but they're going
down they're stupid youtube contacted me
and the copyright take down notice hello
i've been preached we've received the
copyright infringement notifications
below regarding your videos we believe
your content is protected by fair use
fair dealing
or similar
exceptions to copyright protection we
are writing to let you know
we do not
i repeat we do not
plan to remove your videos at this time
do you want to hear more
yeah go ahead bro so at this point it
shows me what the fresh and fit lawyer
okay who i'm gonna admit his name claims
we infringed okay and if you look at the
timestamps the timestamps don't make no
sense they say that we stole 50 minutes
of their content 40 minutes our videos
are never longer than 15 minutes so
already there i don't know who the
lawyer is but he's incompetent but shout
out to him because he's making money off
fresh and fit the same way we are so
shout out to him
hey i feel like you know what their
legal team is just scamming them too you
know what miami is just full of scammers
i'm not gonna feel bad for him walter
scamming his fans the lawyers scamming
fresh and fit karma something like that
if you notice like 20 videos that they
claim we infringe on their copyright
okay so youtube sees this and they reply
hi lawyer
we are concerned that some of the
information in your takedown request may
be fraudulent
please understand that youtube receives
a large number of fraudulent copyright
takedown requests and we take that abuse
of that process very seriously and then
they cite a court case where they [ __ ]
somebody up for doing it then they say
we remind you to take this seriously and
make sure you get it done if we don't
receive a detailed explanation from you
within seven days your youtube account
may be terminated you may be able to
avoid termination if you retract your
takedown request you also have to know
that
if you abuse the system and youtube
finds out you can get your channel
terminated folks but if you go down this
road i'm letting you know it's often
your end that's going to be hit the
hardest hey hey hey bro you know what we
always be [ __ ] on youtube i think we
got to show youtube some love today
yo no problem no yeah yeah for real for
that i got i gotta admit like we've been
saying y'all youtube this youtube dad
youtube okay okay yeah so what is it so
basically what you're saying is that
we're in the ring right now they got
seven guys to retract
yeah like craig david the lawyer then
responds
the lawyer then responds the lawyer says
each of the videos
in question either uses a significant
section of our clients content fresh and
fit
pulled directly from their videos on
youtube channel or have lifted their
entire videos from their youtube channel
furthermore we believe that these videos
in question are all being used for
commercial purposes without alteration
which necessarily defeats any fair use
exceptions to copyright infringement bro
do they know what alteration is hey the
lawyer's getting paid he's making his
money do not argue with what the lawyer
is saying the lawyer is just trying to
stretch this out
yay what he just said makes no sense
without alteration by definition of us
cutting in and interjecting we've
altered it potato brain but anyways i
like this youtube response hello fresh
my man's 28 going on 80 and i don't want
that to be you guys and that's why
today's sponsor t.h henley is coming in
to save the day i get compliments on my
skin all the time people will be asking
what's your skin care routine how do you
get your skin and for a lot of fellas
talking about skin care is a little bit
awkward because either we're too ashamed
to do it or it seems a little bit too
feminine but the truth is having rough
skin or having all these little dents
everywhere isn't something that you
necessarily want especially if it's
things that you can easily avoid through
very very good products i recommend
going through that process and that's
where tiege hanley comes in they got a
great system in place where you can use
their products to achieve your skin care
goals i personally recommend that you
start with the level one system which
comes with all the basics a daily face
wash which gets rid of all the dirt and
grime on your face then got it two times
per week exfoliating scrub to get rid of
all the dead skin cells and an am
moisturizer with spf 20 because we all
need to make sure that our skin is
protected from the sun and the cool
thing about tf channels all their boxes
come with instructions in addition to
amazing skin members of th handling get
tons of benefits like at least twenty
percent off retail price the ability to
pause or cancel at any time as well as
free us shipping and because the channel
is sponsoring today's video if you go to
the link in the description below not
only will you get all the benefits that
i just listed but you'll also get a free
gift with your purchase
robot that fake so you can actually
start looking fresh
thank you for your message however we
remain concerned that your copyright
notification is not valid for some or
all the videos identified in your
notification as a result the content
will remain live on youtube sincerely
the youtube team
and i hope that youtube investigates
this
they're complaining that we're doing the
same thing
exactly
you know what my man let me tell you
this
all of this could have been so easy
everything would just
go on with the boxing match
it would have been easier
but no now you try to copyright things
from a
[ __ ]
easier if i would go down there you set
me a date i do what i gotta do you do
what you gotta do and then that's it but
no
i actually called uh called the gym for
you because i know you were gonna go
down there that weekend and the gym said
yeah not an issue if you pay us a bit
like you can have it have so i was like
cool and priest is going to be there
he's going to have some headgear do it
and these guys are like nah nah we want
to do like a whole jake paul versus i
was like you know you're not j paul i'm
not jake paul i just want
something with my luggage
okay
all i was gonna say is um
yeah and at this point i think they're
really upset that people are talking
about them and doing their content so i
think they went to this length to shut
up anybody who's gonna say anything
negative about them so so they failed
that's pretty much what it is they're
not happy that people are just
uncovering them by using the content and
talking [ __ ] yes you were that much of
an alpha people been talking [ __ ] about
us and it's okay if you are replying to
our video and that's okay do you think
mental lux replied to her video and did
whatever she had to do and i'm i'm
perfectly fine with that i'm perfectly
fine to have a conversation with
[ __ ] it's okay bring what you
got to do we do it it'd be stupid for us
not like for us to be like no samantha
you can't use her that's just dumb
that's stupid that's what you do as well
so let's go
but like i said it is what it is all of
this could have been avoided but i agree
let's go i agree so now that we got the
green light i got a bunch of their
videos already locked up and edited so
we're going to be dropping those so if
you guys didn't want us to cover you now
we definitely will yeah
and i'll be in miami around the 22nd of
december so
oh you gonna be there for christmas
i am mad at that i'm mad at that well
listen i just want to kind of update you
on what's going on the copyright strike
they tried they slang they failed and
youtube is now looking into them for
potential termination so hey man i
warned them i i swear to god i warned
them i said guys don't do this because
it'll come back on you because i know
their content and i know if youtube
takes a look at their channel it won't
last long
no of course not but hey you want
everybody to notice you [ __ ]
are gonna notice you now all right you
want that notoriety
you got it so hopefully you guys enjoyed
today's video now you guys are kind of
kept up to date as for us again i wasn't
bothered by it because i knew we could
litigate this no issue but now uh on
their end hopefully nothing happens i
mean listen i'm not gonna hope nothing
happens i'm not gonna hope something
does happen i don't care if they stay on
this platform we'll cover more stupid
[ __ ] that they say and if they get
deleted i really won't feel bad because
they did bring it on themselves you reap
what you saw so that's it man let us
know what you guys think in the comments
like i said before you make a hit piece
you're going to get hit back legally and
we're going to make sure we hit you
where it hurts your pockets so if you
want to make videos cool there's going
to be consequences frank castle comes in
many forms and sometimes it's legal
recourse so think about what you do next
become a new member welcome brother all
right